boot Lake C podcast go watch our our
interview man the homie Desi hollow's
here repping Oceanside his new album
caught in the funk it's out right now C
the funk oceanides in the house for sure
for sure we going to have K hey let's
let's get to some rapping man all right
come on look o side yes sir look
smashing down the highway and rolling up
at a state lines H is hating on you will
suck your dick at the same time you
should had a hong till your B to catch a
Play Time Solo in the booth all they
doing is waste time pre you can keep it
and leave it tuck to the waistline
before little shorty pull up I tell her
the FaceTime put them off and G my
switch are too short I can't lie cuz
I'mma play a straight up and got to hit
through the Great Vine they don't know
the process behind the meaning it take
time Ted Expeditions and Toes creep in
the daytime did it for the town now a
lot of yall s repetitive fitting by the
dollar then show me the closest exit is
I pay my D foot in the street of the for
Stomp and R of the Beast and his back to
the funk the master back to release
right now I'm hot let me boil could have
H on high I kept that always true to the
s I've been a student to the game so we
made pipes out of foil no expiration day
or B so this shit's never going to spoil
I can't trust nobody that ain't even
check in they oil H and high SCH hitting
me but now they treated me Royal back to
represent to come up with this game it
is finest and once this [__] hit Snoopy
be like what do you finest promotion
side of Long Beach huh racking up these
[__] G's huh B to The Hustle No
clocking out never closing Cemetery
roses a pay attention reposes we grew up
around the blocks of the water out water
hoses looking for a high but we never
play what I know I parted ways for the
FK now follow me like it's Moses the
King of Funk come on come on oan size in
the house ble woo Desi hollow man that's
how we doing it in 2024 baby go get his
new album right now call in the funk
that was hard brother good [__] just a
quick appr fire hey you just watched
another freestyle brought to you by the
good Folks at LRG goddamn it shout out
to LRG all right go use the promo code
bootleg right now on their website
l-r-g.com say 40% off at checkout 40%
off at checkout use that promo code and
we got another freestyle coming ASAP